creo que ya estamos aprendiendo bastante
bien cómo multiplicar fracciones así que
por ejemplo si en esta ocasión yo tengo
22 entre entre 4 entre 3 mejor entre 3
que va a multiplicar que va a
multiplicar a 4 ok 4 sobre 5 sobre lo
voy a poner con este color sobre 5 ok
bueno como vimos en el vídeo pasado ya
sabemos qué significa tener dos tercios
por cuatro quintos o al menos como
operarlo dos tercios por cuatro quintos
es exactamente lo mismo dado lo que
vimos el vídeo pasado que multiplicamos
el numerador por el numerador es decir
aquí voy a poner un por aquí voy a poner
un x vamos a multiplicar el numerador
que es 2
por el otro numerador que es 4 2 por 4 y
esto lo vamos a dividir es decir vamos a
tener como denominador la multiplicación
de los denominadores es decir 3 por 5 3
por 5 multiplicó los dos numeradores
quedan arriba multiplicó los dos
denominadores que han abajo y bueno esto
sabemos que es exactamente lo mismo que
dos por cuatro lo cual es 88 sobre 3 por
5 lo cual es 15 ok ahora date cuenta que
8 sobre 15 es una fracción irreducible y
no se puede reducir porque 8 y 15 no
tienen factores en común o bueno si el
único factor que tienen en común es 1
sin contar alumnos no tienen factores en
común y por lo tanto no podemos reducir
más esta fracción esta es una fracción
irreducible ahora lo que quiero ver en
este vídeo es analizar qué significan
estas dos expresiones dos tercios por
cuatro quintos y para eso vamos a verlo
de una manera visual
y voy a dibujar aquí un rectángulo lo
más grande que pueda se me ocurre a este
rectángulo de aquí y vamos a verlo de
manera visual en dos formas distintas
así que primero voy a dividir a este
rectángulo que va a ser mi entero en
tres partes iguales aquí tengo una y
aquí tengo a más o menos por acá tengo
la otra ok
supongamos que estas tres partes son
exactamente iguales y que significan dos
tercios de este entero bueno significa
que voy a colorear dos de estas tres
partes de este entero y por lo tanto
vamos a cambiar este color y voy a
tomarme a una espera déjame que me dé
herramienta una o que me voy a tomar
esta de kim ok algo así y no voy a tomar
esto también esto también me la voy a
tomar coloreada para que así tengamos
dos tercios de este entero ok ahora si a
estos dos tercios los multiplicó por
cuatro sobre cinco por cuatro quintos
fíjate que mi resultado tiene como
denominador el 15 por lo tanto necesito
aquí dividir a éste entero en 15 partes
déjeme tomar ahora este color voy a usar
este color y vamos a dividir a este
entero en 15 partes iguales lo que es lo
mismo voy a dividir cada una de estas
tres secciones en cinco partes cinco
partes iguales así que empecemos una ok
dos ok
tres ok cuatro ok y voy a hacer lo mismo
con ésta una ok dos ok
3 4
ok supongamos que son partes iguales y
aquí voy a hacer lo mismo una ok 2 o que
tres o cuatro ok
supongamos que cada una de estas partes
son partes iguales y entonces fíjate que
ahora tengo a este entero dividida en 5
5 5 en 15 partes iguales y si tengo este
entero dividido en 15 partes iguales que
significan y ahora sí fíjate bien qué
significa tener dos tercios multiplicado
por cuatro
quintos bueno de una manera visual dos
tercios multiplicado por cuatro quintos
significa tomarme de estos dos tercios
de estos dos tercios que colorean de
estos dos tercios que tengo aquí me voy
a tomar cuatro quintas partes de ellos
es decir cuando multiplico dos tercios
por cuatro quintos lo que estoy haciendo
es tomarme cuatro quintos de estas dos
terceras partes y bueno para eso date
cuenta que tenemos hasta ahorita
coloreados uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho nueve diez pedazos diez
pedazos de estos quince esos son dos
tercios pero como quiero tomar cuatro
quintos de estos diez pedazos
bueno si yo tengo diez cosas y quiero
tomarme cuatro quintos de esas diez
cosas realmente lo que tengo que hacer
es tomarme ocho de ellos por lo tanto
cuatro quintos de dos tercios es
colorear a de estos 8 es decir voy a
tomarme aquí 1
2 ok 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 es decir que cuando
yo me tomo dos tercios y lo multiplicó
por cuatro quintos me estoy tomando
cuatro quintas partes de estos dos
tercios dos tercios representaban diez
sobre quince de todas estas partes que
tengo aquí y cuando yo me tomo los
cuatro quintos cuando lo multiplicó por
cuatro juntos me voy a tomar solamente
los cuatro quintos de estas diez partes
que tenía coloreadas cuatro quintos por
dos tercios
es lo mismo que 8 sobre 15 815 a vos y
si te das cuenta aquí tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 8 de estos 15 coloreados 8 15 ambos
perfecto ya lo vimos de una manera
visual ahora qué te parece que te parece
si lo vemos desde la otra perspectiva
vamos a empezar con estos cuatro quintos
por lo tanto déjame hacer aquí
entero otra vez de lujo y ahora voy a
dividirlo en quintas partes es decir voy
a dividir este entero en 5 supongamos
que aquí tengo una ok vamos a ver si me
quedan 2 ok
3 ok
4 ok y está perfecto aquí tengo mis 5
partes me entero dividido en cinco
partes y de estas cinco partes me voy a
tomar cuatro quintos ok y para tomarme
cuatro quintos lo voy a tomar con este
color
así que dibujemos déjame cambiar cuatro
quintas partes a esperar déjame
cambiarlo mejor al mismo color que el 4
que es un color verde así que voy a
dibujar una ok
ok 3
ok 4 ok y no voy a tomar cuatro quintos
cuatro quintos de este entero ya están
de lujo ahora cuando yo me tomo dos
tercios multiplicando a cuatro quintos
quiero que te des cuenta que mi
resultado está dividido en 15 partes por
lo tanto voy a dividir a este entero en
15 partes y eso quiere decir que cada
una de estas 5 partes en las cuales
tengo dividido a este entero las voy a
dividir en 3 3 por 5 es 15 por lo tanto
vamos a hacer lo voy a dividir cada una
de estas partes y déjame cambiar a este
color cada una de estas partes en las
que tengo dividido en mi entero lo voy a
dividir en tres así que tomemos una ok 2
de lujo aquí también una ok 2 ok
aquí también una ok 2 ok si te das
cuenta a cada una de estas partes lo
estoy dividiendo en tres pedazos aquí
también
ok 2 y ahora a esta última quinta parte
lo voy a dimitir también en tres pedazos
una
2 de tal manera que quiero que te des
cuenta que aquí abajo tenemos este
entero dividido ahora en 15 partes
iguales 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
y 15 cuando yo me tomo de estos cuatro
quintos que tengo coloreados aquí dos
tercios lo que estoy representando es
que me voy a tomar dos tercios de estos
cuatro quintos que ya tenía coloreados y
si estos cuatro quintos representan
hasta ahorita 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
12 partes coloreadas cuando yo me tomo
dos tercios de estas 12 partes
coloreadas no estoy tomando realmente 8
partes imagínate que yo tengo 12
manzanas y lo voy a dividir en tres si
lo divido en tres hago grupos de cuatro
y si de estos grupos de cuatro me tomo 2
voy a tomarme 88 manzanas por lo tanto
voy a colorear 8 de estas partes
déjame cambiar de color una a la voy a
colorear ahora sí
ok 22
ok 33 ok 44 55 55 56 66 67 77 7 77 77 y
88 partes de estas 15 partes que tengo
aquí están ahora coloreadas de este
color salmón y lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que es lo que representan dos
tercios por cuatro quintos visto desde
esta perspectiva es tomarme estos cuatro
quintos y de estos cuatro quintos voy a
calcular dos tercios de ellos por lo
tanto llegó a 8 sobre 15 y si te das
cuenta
aquí también tengo uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho partes de estas
quince coloreadas y llegamos casi al
mismo punto de una manera visual estamos
viendo que representa tomar
una multiplicación de fracciones en este
caso dos tercios por cuatro quintos es
tomarme dos terceras partes de estas
cuatro quintas partes o en su dado caso
tomarme cuatro quintas partes de estas
dos terceras partes